[Music]
um so
ethan klein went on uh tiger belly to
destroy jewish fella
i mean i think he's asian he looks like
a woman in a renaissance painting look
at that bottom left [ __ ]
oh my god he does he looks like somebody
should be feeding him [ __ ] milk and
honey you know what he looks like
do you remember the hedonism bought from
futurama oh my god
yes
i trust her
what a reverence i don't know
oh my god i just googled it oh my god
that is a [ __ ] dead eye here this is
bring me wine and underage boys
[Laughter]
the hedonism bot is perfect reference
except ethan climbs the hebanism
[Laughter]
oh that was good even
is
no my darling bring me more palestinian
corpses
oh god
[Laughter]
glad we're not on youtube today oh [ __ ]
so glad so very glad here you go you're
immersed there's a better one for you
fantastic
oh
okay sorry um
not that you brought up the the the
thing that the gotcha thing let's just
go like we're going to let you go the
thing that you when you we came under
your ship oh he's so bobby lee's upset
that when he came on the show he kind of
felt ambushed about the whole
relationship thing and all that stuff
and the brian callan stuff and the
reddit stuff no right and you said you
brought up the
the schwab
see i don't even want to say it but yeah
that well let's not pretend like it
didn't happen yeah it did happen when
you brought that up we didn't know that
you were going to bring that up so what
i don't i know my point is that i
understand that but what i'm saying is
is that that's what you are
no dude no you're a gotcha guy no it's
not true
yes it is true actually you know what
i'm on bobby's side because even though
i think [ __ ] crowder sucks crowder
actually was in good faith gonna go on
his show and talk to ethan one on one
and then he had that other guy come in
and try to debate him so you are in a
gotcha guy and that's fine if you want
to be sam yeah i remember that yeah is
this entire [ __ ] mo
seriously yeah and also if you go back
and watch the original clip how giddy he
was while he was asking him it like he
knew what he was asking he knew they
were getting into some [ __ ]
that's a good point he was really giddy
when he was asking him the question
yeah so andy i don't think he likes
being called out you know what i mean
for him no he does
he
healer darling i do not like these
accusations this
oriental railroad worker is throwing my
way
i'm not attached and i have to be honest
with you dude it did
ask her for that day i didn't like you
i was actually it wasn't i thought you
think i know but i was but it was it got
bro
bothers me it's like
it's like certain people just can like
do things with really bad intentions and
then like just effortlessly lie about it
like it's almost like it comes naturally
to them almost like they're just born
with an inclination to be devious but
what i don't understand this it's like
it really does blow my mind with with
this it's like
ethan is is known to look at the whole
keemstar fight with keemstar ethan has
been known is known for trying to get
people de-platformed right like he's
known for that and he goes after all
these people and then that's [ __ ] if you
want to be guy that guy that's fine but
when somebody calls you out because you
like being drama guy or because you want
a clip don't pretend it wasn't a gotcha
because you literally clipped it on your
channel it would with like with with
salacious headline
so it was a gotcha thing and at least
admit yeah okay that's what i do but
what bothers me is that like
he pretends like
he pretends like that's not the guy he
is
that's what you are you started out
ethan started before all the politics
and stuff making fun of people that were
doing like those fake um prank videos
remember for like a while they're like
10 years ago there was an epidemic of
fake prank videos that everyone
pretended were real before before ethan
got political that's what he did it was
a gotcha i got you here i got you again
look this is fake
you met your career has got your guy
so angry first of all let me let it's
like okay and then with the mole thing
after that it's just like exact double
doctor i knew it's a double gotcha so my
point is
so i'm just saying i love you no it's
good you're getting it out there yeah
but let's talk about it okay yeah yeah
so when you guys came on the podcast
we scheduled it way ahead of time yeah
and i told you beforehand
this is a live podcast
i mean well he's uncomfortable in
general yeah i mean
he's a he's a twitchy blinky neurotic
mess who
has five shells for a shotgun that he
keeps locked and separate
i haven't made it very clear you guys
this is a live show i did barely knew
anything about the brandon thing it
wasn't even a big topic on my you know
in my head to hit
but i knew it was a thing and so i like
that's a lie man that's the biggest
thing that was out there stop be honest
you're a piece of [ __ ] but i would
respect you more if you were an honest
piece of [ __ ] you know
stop ask people about everything that's
interesting going on in their life and
it was an interesting thing i thought
and i asked about it and you guys i felt
opened the floodgate on that i sat back
look at that he did exactly what you
said he redirected it
and blame them yeah
we watched it royce it's almost as if
he's
crying out in pain as he strikes them
oh so to speak got it
and let it happen weird right you coined
that that's pretty clever
ben and i felt like you guys were giving
it to me and i was just taking what was
out there i did i don't feel i coaxed
you okay orca no yeah you did you asked
uncomfortably and i remember even bobby
lee remember bodybuilding said i really
don't want to talk about that and then
you pushed it
all right or manipulated you guys at all
you acting real usy
frankly i resent the insinuation oh wait
a second
so now he's hurt
now you he's the hurt one oh my god this
is play-by-play you know frankly i'm the
victim here this is play-by-play i'm
suing bobby lee
really yes if i go to a damn right and i
put a little explosive on the damn right
i didn't
just listen what i'm saying
if i go to a damn i put a little
explosive on the damn right and the damn
bird this is a terrible metaphor to be
one of the good ones and this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
squirt gun well because he's the size of
three of them pez you have your work cut
out
see pessy at least admits that it takes
effort and energy and you have to
actually make a concerted effort to not
be one of the bad ones
yeah i mean when you have depression
sometimes it's hard to laugh at yourself
but i do my goddamn darkness but here's
the problem pez even though you're like
very jewish and i've seen you um and
even with all that it doesn't matter
because you'll be the self-hating one
you'll be the one that's the problem
there's no winning
they these people have all made up their
mind and they'll have their little
[ __ ] club and you know they all yell
at each other but the moment you try to
do something funny or even do what they
used to do
they immediately come after you so you
know i don't respect anybody that's
sitting here but honestly if you ask me
who i respect the least
i [ __ ] delilah
is she because she's a woman
no because she [ __ ] her brother
brothers
brothers
she jerked off dogs she jerked off dogs
and she's [ __ ] oh look
if she admitted to jerking off the dog
do you think she didn't [ __ ] it how do
you think how do you why do you think
her dogs have monkey pox
uh oh ergy
virgie she didn't [ __ ] the dog after
jerking it off it ate her out now uh
back to ethan though that's why that's
why there's so much peanut butter in
that household
i i get what you're saying royce but i
don't believe that's why they're second
peanut butter and her [ __ ]
i don't believe for a second that when
ethan kline looks in a mirror he he
loves he likes what he sees
no i don't think when even klein looks
at the bed next to him he likes what he
sees forget the mirror
he really is just a disgusting looking
creature
what do you mean
that's so [ __ ] dude
my god man
we pulled that reference out of nowhere
gila darling i'm cold bring me
i don't know 17 beanies to wear on top
of one another
only the finest teddy fresh
in this household
[ __ ] i farted in your teddy fresh i
guess now it's teddy fowl
[Laughter]
this water comes through right yeah i
can't then just go you know i didn't
know
right yeah i had all this [ __ ] honor
what was gonna come what i didn't put it
explosive
yeah you did you put a little wow you
think in your mind right that you
bringing up the brenda shop is a little
thing guys
you could what i'm saying let me finish
what i'm saying right yeah but bobby
i mean you clip this so you also want
the attention
right but what
and my throat's getting sore my throats
are polyps yeah right i'm going to throw
it to the blood but what i'm saying
right is is that you knew right no
yes
i knew what i'll tell you i knew what i
knew what you know that we're podcasters
right it's not like you're not if we're
not people that you're having on that
you have no
knowledge of who they are what they do
you know
what the [ __ ] you know how to edit you
know
[ __ ] dino you know how to talk and
what not to talk about and if you did
actually not very good at because you
know well that's not my problem mr
[ __ ] explosives on the dam
and these guys are friends
apparently [ __ ]
they're they're all they're all terrible
people and they all hate each other and
they all deserve it yeah you're right
they all hate each other and they all
hate themselves it's beautiful